I think the biggest thing is disrespect
the buildup of that can get to a point
where someone just feels that they can't
live with that person anymore okay I did
see that this brother or this sister
wasn't good for me but ultimately I
still went ahead with it the one who's
willing to walk away from the
negotiation is the the one who's more
powerful in the negotiation the reason
being because a lot of male suicide is
actually linked to the breakup of
relationships and a lot of female
traumatic experiences are linked to
marital issues men when they marry
firstly it's all about looks and when
they marry and realize I married a then
they come to reality they're like okay
this girl was 10 out of 10 whatever but
she made my life living hell on Earth so
marriage is not cure for a man or a
woman who are addicted to pornography or
a toxic person or a Mommy's boy they say
a soulmate is somebody who you decide to
make it work with there's no one that's
meant to be it's someone that you decide
that you're going going to make it work
with that person I think we need to
start looking like other brother said
closer to home so rather than looking
for Role Models online look at home look
at how your dad treats your mom and if
he doesn't treat her right learn from
that understand that that's not how I'm
going to treat my wife or my husband you
don't pray Salah you commit major sins
you violate Allah's legislation and then
you're surprised why is my life forget
your wife why is life not going right
why is this happening home it's direct
consequences in sin another thing about
a counselor is by by definition a
counselor is not to necessarily tell you
what to do and they're not supposed to
judge they're supposed to guide you
they're supposed to help you reach your
own conclusion when Mar disputes happen
the husband or the wife goes to somebody
else and now they're giving advice based
on their marriage and their standards
and they're like brother yours is bisoke
for you lots of men are married to women
who do not wear hijab right and then
later on down the line it's like put
your hijab
on
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a sar for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation you will in
be reaping the reward click the link and
donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends hobby guys in welcome to another
episode of The Bitter truth show uh
we'll be discussing a very very
important topic which is affecting
everybody globally especially the Muslim
Community which is the breakdown of the
family unit why is that happening um but
before we start brothers and sisters uh
on the panel uh the bit of buzzles are
there if you have a disagreement with
somebody just press it and they'll have
that is invalid you don't you don't with
the champ you can't do that does even
work why is it working oh press it
properly broke it okay
yeah has on it makes a different sound I
didn't touch it though
okay so the topic at hand is basically
the breakdown of the family unit Why are
marriages breaking down so if you
disagree with someone you press it they
have one and a half minute please don't
interrupt that person let them speak and
after one and a half minute I will stop
them um and yeah no backbiting no
slandering and inshallah yes um Accord
to Islamic e eates so the topic at hand
is very simple we know for example
divorce rates are affecting everybody I
think there was study done that in
America nearly 40% or 50% of women are
single mothers yeah and yeah and and if
we look at 30 40 years ago that was
about 5% so we can see where the
trajectory is
going before that let's just you know
got uh introduce yourself in sister from
sister f onwards this way so my name is
Fana and I'm a relationship coach and a
therapist I work with Muslim women and
uh couples Muslim women and couples um
to help them guide them through their
relationship so it can go either way so
it can be a marriage that has to end or
a marriage that can be saved so I work
with the you're at the front lines ald
battling this ald so i' be very
insightful sister Ira asum my name is
sistera Dean I work in a school and I
have firstand experience being a second
um single mom second yeah and uh sister
I've
got your name s gisen so I'm gisen um I
work in higher education um I also
volunteer supporting uh members of the
Omar navigate the legal system in the
country we to um Family inter divorce um
and I also have uh experience with uh
being a single one but also being
divorced as well yeah and sister
dopamine well I go by Dr dopamine but on
here you can call me sister doerman and
I'm a newly life coach that has
specialized in relationships but mainly
with people who have had toxic
relationships and Trauma um yeah so and
new on social media so I'm zishan I'm a
YouTuber educator journalist uh
Mah hi um my name is Mubarak um so I
work in finance and I'm 21 um I don't
really have experience with like
relationship stuff but yeah yes and
we've got hij in which needs no
introduction bless him yeah so in show
guys let's get straight into the topic
if you think about it you know I was
talk about taking the over the yeah and
and I will say this it's basically
taking our logical processes over what
Allah has prescribed look guys you need
to understand there's sins have
consequences you you look at you look at
the Surah yeah it is told that for
example and Allah subhana tala um is not
with it's can't remember the verse but
in the natural meaning that consequences
of your sins Bro you've got married
couple this woman she doesn't even pray
Salah this man doesn't even know his
case bro you're in sin you're swimming
in sin and then you're thinking actually
the Sal would say that they would go and
if they knew they committed a sin
argument s they looked arguments say for
to a woman they didn't lower their Gates
when they come home they will see their
wife wilding out they would know which
sin connects where they would know you
know what bro it's that sin that I did
that I'm seeing it coming out in my wife
in my w my riding Beast meaning what the
point is what the sins that you commit
have an impact before these coaches and
this wall have you ever
explored yourself going to the commands
of Allah subhana tala do you even pray
Salah you don't pray Salah you commit
major sins you violate Allah's
legislation and then you're surprised
why is my life forget your wife why is
life not going right why is this
happening home it's direct consequences
in sin and what we do is we say oh I
need to go to a marriage course brother
first fix your relationship with Allah
if you've done that if you're like you
know what we pray our Salah together yes
yes we don't commit major sins we do all
of this then I will say brother go check
a counsel out man just try it but you
don't even do that how many Muslims are
committing sins over sins what you earn
that the prophet said he pointed at man
and said what he drinks is Haram what he
wears is Haram and you want good results
W it's mindboggling bro you don't even
give the basic h of Allah subhana wa
tala and then you come and complain
I'mma Speakers Corner some s come and go
I'm find it hard to get married Bro I
ask a simple question my dear sister how
is your relationship with Salah do you
know what's the
reply and I'm thinking what the audacity
man you don't even give the basic h of
Allah and why can't I get married why
are things not going right how do you
want it to go right so the first thing
is the Crux of the matter is
what your obedience to Allah everything
from the where you walk towards what you
hear what you see sins have a
consequence and you commit the sins
indulge indul indulge indulge and then
oh this my wife ising up this should
video no
but the video the power to edit yeah
because we're cutting your bit
definitely no joking bro you know what's
actually important your this bit
alhamdulillah this this is important and
then what you said is so profound then
you can say can can we cut out the
marriage with the intent of
people I are you reading my heart so the
point is this yeah is that what W I
swear what Allah subhana wa tala sent is
H if you guys do that please W the
recipe is in the Quran is unbelievable
the one who created the heavens and the
Earth has given you a recipe if you went
to your doctor and your doctor said you
need to do ABC you be like yeah yeah
yeah I need to do that he knows what
he's talking about the one who created
the heavens and the Earth is giving you
a recipe you turn your back on it and
then you cry all I'm saying is very
simple if you just pray your on time giv
fasting be good alhamdulillah stay away
from major sins then if you say you know
what there's some Rift then you can say
now this is human psychology okay
something's okay go to a counselor then
but before that you're dreaming if you
think you're going to go to a counselor
and the counselor is going to fix your
problem the one that's going to fix your
problem is the one who's created you
this is the Crux of the matter in
everything we do inshah yeah so in show
guys let's get straight into the topic
which is why are marriages breaking down
now let's start with sister because you
are dealing with this head on
um so where do you think this is
stemming from and is it most your CLI
are they sisters or brothers sisters so
you didn't sister okay that's sisters or
couples sisters or couples okay that's
good when you see two individuals
married couple come into get this you
know uh handle this
coaching what is what do you see the
problem is like where do you because
there's so many like people say it's
because of this or it's because of that
everyone's putting their finger on
something but from your point of view
and your experience farano where is is
this stemming from this divorce divorce
and it's becomes so rampant like please
tell us okay so if we look on a surface
level you know when people say Okay um
previously there was a to topic on uh
whether the husband gives flowers or not
so that's the surface level we're
looking at we have to go into a deeper
level in the sense that why are these
relationships breaking down so it's not
just about lack of romance it's not just
about lack of a physical relationship
all these factors but there could be
factors such as uh a dealing with them
disabilities where the wife may have a
disability the husband may have a
disability or there might be domestic
violence there might be lack of
Community Support lack of family support
toxic relationships so there are many
many many factors to why a relationship
breaks down I think the mistake that we
make the biggest mistake we make is
believing that what it is on you know
movies Bollywood all these kind of
things this is not real life so we try
to compare marriages
on most of the time I'm not saying
everyone but I'm not generalizing this
topic at all but a lot of times it's
kind of going that way this is what a
relationship should be when we know as
Muslim brothers and sisters there's more
to a marriage you know it's not just um
yeah it completes half your Dean but
then there are other factors as well
that play a part in what makes a good
marriage or what breaks a marriage so
you would say I think that's very
interesting because you're basically
saying there are these false
expectations this reality and I think
that plays a big factor because people
are consuming material which we had a
discussion here in the bit trick which
was irresponsible social media couples
who were portraying this lifestyle of
and and let me tell you something I know
one specific scenario which this brother
I actually know him now kind of
personally is that they are social media
couple not that big and they after
talked about them you he gave his
permission if you go into their
Instagram
if I said to you here's a case there's
this brother he's in the cell he's been
accused of RP he's been accused of that
and violence yeah R sorry thank you Zan
didn't I say that anyways thank you
anyways so he's been accused of
something very severe and he's huh yeah
so the things he's been accused of that
and now he's in a Cell yeah and then the
wife has run off with the child and if I
showed you this the the Instagram
account and I said to you would you ever
in the millionaires think that these are
the two Coupes you see what you see here
with flowers roses everything looks
romantic this is exactly the situation I
went to the social media and I was like
this is unbelievable I showed it to my
wife I said what do you think about
these are they such a cute couple look
at them they're so happy I you know he's
in the cell and by the way she's run off
with a kid did you know that social Serv
involved she's said no way I said well
I'm on the phone uh to this uh brother
so this is the reality that we're
dealing with false expectation and
watching you know these things and expec
it to be in the real world what about
you guys cuz some of s have been
divorced as well um what would you say
is the cause of this because sister fan
has pointed from to a very specific
issue um I mean from my own personal
experience and also the experiences that
I've um lived through through supporting
others within the Omar I think the
biggest thing is
disrespect um and when it it can be a
disrespect that happens once and ruins
the relationship or it could be
disrespect that's built over time um
usually it's something that's over time
from what I've seen um and I think we
all have limits as humans
to what what we can take and how much
disrespect we can take and I think that
is probably the the biggest Factor um in
relationship or marriages breaking down
you define as sy sry just CU people can
use that broadly sadly people take that
and they're like oh yeah I feel this is
respectful no it's not what do you
define as
disrespect so anything that challenges
the Integrity of the other person that's
actually a very good
definition yeah it's a good short hand
like you just thought about that on the
SP yeah um so you know and integrity in
itself is defined um I won't go too much
into that but anything that yeah so
essentially that um the buildup of that
can get to a point where someone just
feels that they it's just they can't
live with that person anymore and when
it gets to that point it's almost a
point of no return and for a lot of the
times it is a point of no return um and
it's not something that humans can
forget either you know um it's very
difficult to come back from that buildup
or even it could just be one major thing
that just kind of ruins um that marriage
and and that will be it um but there are
other kind of uh Second Place third
place Reasons from my experience I would
say probably second place is uh too much
interference or just interference of
external parties um normally in certain
cultures tends to be family members and
it's not necessarily positive input
obviously um it's whether it's like kind
of a dictation over um how the
relationship should be or questioning
why that Dynamic is that way um so that
can start planting seeds in either the
the wife or the husband's mind and you
know when you start bringing up oh my
you know so and so said this and so and
so said that when there's a third party
even hypothetically involved in your
mind that kind of makes you lose trust
in that relationship um so yeah I was
going to very key very key I was going
to say that um I like that analysis I
think that was very it's good analysis
in fact
most most studies that I've looked at on
this matter cuz obviously look we've got
Islamic specific issues then you've got
like the broader
population um there's what is referred
to in the psychological literature as
the force The Four Horsemen of marital
breakdown a marital failure I'm not sure
if you've come across this but this is
probably one of the most offre repeated
comments if you look at these studies
actual studies peer reviewed
psychological studies on marital
breakdown and the four four horsemen are
the following first one is criticism
partner criticism so where the person
starts to criticize another person
obviously every partnership is going to
CR like you're going to have criticism
happening right but if it reaches a
certain threshold where you're in the
presence of your husband or your wife
and all that's happening is that that
person's criticizing you or you're
criticizing them then you're creating an
atmosphere where it's it's antagonistic
it's not a proper atmosphere right so
you feel like you're actually at work in
the relationship more than you should be
so that's the first thing the second
thing is which is connected to it is
defensiveness so what happens is when
you have a conversation with your
partner you always feel like you need to
be on edge you need to defend yourself
you feel like a defendant in a court
room or something like that so
defensiveness is you shouldn't feel like
in a sense every human being needs a
their safe space to be vulnerable and if
you feel like with your partner that
you're always needing to defend yourself
or Justify or excuse make and this kind
of stuff and that actually can lead to
marital breakdown uh the third thing is
uh cont yes contempt right so like
resentment basically right now some
psychologists they do differentiate
between resentment and uh contemptuous
nature but let's just say for the sake
of argument let's use them
interchangeably when someone has this
feeling of negative this
embitterment and that so how they Define
it in the studies it's usually like a
negative feeling felt towards the
partner for a sustained period of time
so you you actually have a negative
opinion of your partner effectively like
if you were to to objectively be asked
what is that person you will have more
negative things to say about them than
positive that kind of State of Affairs
cannot last for a long time and the
fourth thing is called
stonewalling stonewalling is when you're
actively ignored and it's a poor
communication technique used by both men
and women like you can speak to your
husband or wife let's say for example
you're speaking to your wife and she
starts not not answering you she's
ignoring you now she's she's pretending
to play Death she doesn't hear anything
that you're saying now if someone feels
ignored in the relation goes back to
what you're saying it's disrespect now
it goes back to okay now I don't feel
integrous anymore I feel like I'm being
disrespected these are the four reasons
like I don't think they're
non-applicable to the Muslim Community I
think there's no reason to believe that
Muslims are going to have completely
specific issues it could be that for
example issues to do with the dominant
ideologies equality and something a lot
of them do mention equality we don't
have that kind of managerial equality is
clearly a reason like for example
feminism I I would say if if you did a
study in the Muslim Community it'
probably have a disproportionate impact
as to how it actually breaks down a
family uh abuse I agree with that
physical actual abuse happening from the
the man to the woman where he can't
control his emotions now anytime he gets
angry he's using his hand he's he's
getting physical and she's had enough of
it it makes her sick and abuse is not
just physical it could be emal psych
it's true but then it can become very
ambiguous if we like use that cuz Stone
Walling some can say it's abuse it's
abusive Behavior but really and truly I
mean islamically speaking there has to
be something there has to be boundaries
that has to like how are we're going to
Define this thing so yeah I don't I
don't think that there's much more
analysis to be made I just feel like if
every rights and responsibilities are
understood okay that's one thing but
when these things happen frankly guys I
mean it could just happen because these
guys are not compatible the sahabis the
companions they had divorce happening I
mean it just because maybe he doesn't he
doesn't like this person she doesn't
like him there's a very famous Hadith
of I'm not sure if you've heard of it
very interesting and it kills I mean
it's one of the worst Hadith for red
pill yeah yeah it's very bad but because
basically this this guy he's chasing
after effectively chasing after his
wife crying in public in front of
everyone for him to for her to take him
back to the point where
wasam went and interceded for him and he
said why don't you take him back she
goes are you telling me because this is
a religious obligation or are you
telling me this as a matter of advice he
said no I'm only advising you it's not a
religious obligation she said I'm not on
it effectively he said okay leave it be
so he had to live with that pain the the
point I'm making is that I mean that I'm
not saying that's positive trait here
this is he shouldn't have done that that
sahabi wrong behavior from the sahabi
just like drinking alcohol from some
sahab is wrong Behavior it's nothing to
be following but I'm saying that
at the same time what you do have is
sometimes you just have one party that's
on it and one party that's not on it you
feel this person the other person
doesn't feel you this person doesn't
like you there's no chemistry it's not
happening so then there's a partner
breakdown and I don't think that partner
breakdown is the worst thing that can
happen in the world because then they
can find another person true but do you
think you think that's the reasons why
for example this this is happening cuz I
don't think these issues of course if
people are not compatible they don't
like each other yeah but I don't think
that's that's the reason like one of the
things is false expectations we spoke
but s and then
maybe yeah I want to add to the
expectations but I also want to add to
compromising on red flags okay so a lot
of the people I deal with they have
these issues in the marriage but in the
beginning they were always there so like
you have a guy or a girl that might come
and say oh my wife or my husband's doing
this now whatever whatever and it's like
okay but in the beginning when you go
back to the beginning when you met the
person they were doing these toxic
things in the beginning right so over a
period of time whether it's the woman or
the man okay I'm just going to use
myself as example there's things I seen
in the beginning of my marriage that I
knew that were going to be problematic
later on down the line and I chose to
compromise on those things right so
those things had consequences and when
you have to deal with the consequences
over a period of time a lot of people
don't want to accept that this is why
you want to now exit the marriage and
it's both sides male and female and I
just genuinely think it's expectations
compromising on red flags and just
seeing that this person is clearly like
you said um not compatible with you and
in the end automatic it's just going to
end in divorce because like you said
nobody's going to live over a period of
time with somebody they're not
compatible with it's just like you know
oil and water it doesn't mix you know
and over a period of time people find oh
he's not doing this she's not doing that
but it's like but you compromised that
on that in the beginning and again it's
again accountability saying okay I did
see that this brother or this sister
wasn't good for me but ultimately I
still went ahead with it because a lot
of people are desperate a lot of people
are doing it for their family a lot of
people are doing getting married for the
wrong reasons um I believe you should
get married for the Arid and not
actually for the dun because if you're
getting married for dun then there's all
the little things that come in oh he's
Rich oh he's got money oh she's pretty
and and you know later on down the line
you see the sister takes a hijab off and
she's not pretty or the brother ain't
Rich he broke you know and a lot of the
times this is why people are getting
divorced because of petty stuff but they
compromised on it in the beginning well
you said uh something you said that in
the beginning you compromised with um
red flags yeah you said red flags and
you said you had to compromise um sorry
if it's personal but like is that what
ended your marriage okay then then can
someone not say then why did you even
compromise if you knew their red flags
why did you even compromise knowing that
eventually you're not going to cuz you
know something lot people say like for
example with females for example the way
you guys are built as well is you have
this perception you know
um like you know you have this
perception I'll change him you know it's
this you looks like a masterpiece I'm
going to I'm going to fix him you know
how you have this cuz you guys like
Adventure and stuff like that yeah is
that no no let's be honest because it's
in it's in your like um your
blood yeah so so so she would agree with
sop yeah okay so then would you not say
then in that instance you're picking
these men yeah do you get trying say are
the ones we are doing it then what then
then what do we do because I also think
that if you if you really
like I haven't said anything yet that's
why I press I thought he's just going to
go on for
ages okay do you want to go first no no
no are you sure I was going to say I
also think that like if if a woman is
really interested in a man she will
compromise at a very high
level and maybe maybe VI maybe vice
versa a man would yeah yeah but can we
can we can I can I just add I just add
to what you said remember what I'm
saying it's the consequences of the red
uh the Red Flags Okay so say let me just
give a example say a guy uh or say I'm a
toxic female right and I um I'm I like
to argue with my husband and be
disrespectful yeah no problem and the
the guy notices about this about me
right in the beginning and but oh she's
so pretty oh she cooks good really but
you know he marries his sister based on
this really shallow stuff and then later
down the line oh she's not doing this or
she's not being obedient or she's not
practicing or she's not covering her
hair and it's like but you compromised
in the beginning now this is the
consequence so it's either you deal with
it or you don't okay good point please
please remember this point yeah cuz I'm
going to
touch on a purely Islamic perspective
yes so for example if I get married to a
woman yeah like and I say these are my
conditions yeah and now she doesn't like
those conditions mhm so what I'll do is
I'll say fine you have have an ultimatum
you either continue in this situation or
I will divorce you she says I'm going to
continue in this situation I don't I
don't want to I cannot continue I say
you're divorced so in a sense I've got
the trump card like in a in a way I
don't need to compromise with anyone
exactly do you know what I mean like in
a sense that if I don't want something
I'm not no one's going to force even
this this sahab this woman she didn't
compromise she didn't like the guy she
went to the propham that's it you know
there's some things I'm never going to
in some cases the man is more severe
obviously I've got
it's more instant more but what I'm
saying is compromise what I don't I
don't I I refuse to compromise actually
do you know what I mean like what
happens if I refuse to compromise do you
know what I mean don't get married
sister come to this point it's fine if
you get married
sister one and a half minutes okay
touching on the subject of compromise
okay we have to look on a deeper level
why are these people compromising what
are their vulnerabilities what are those
hidden traumas and everything that they
now think that if I don't compromise I'm
going to end up alone and this happens
on many occasions so not many people
think on a you know level of psychology
or neuroscience and all these um
modalities so we have to go back and
think okay who are these people why
these decisions being made and are
people who are on that level making the
right the same choices are their
marriages ending on the same basis uh
marriage would end who someone who's not
qualified in Psychology or counseling or
all these subjects so not just looking
at okay these people are compromising
because they know it all and they've
seen the red flags and that's the reason
they know the red flags are there and
they can deal with them later so we we
have to understand I think this goes
back to 20 seconds I'm so sorry just so
we just that's fine that's fine okay I
was going to say this goes back to what
we were saying in the previous episode
which is that thei of the
Prophet that they're self-sufficient
from the people if I know like for me
the most important thing is what I want
I've going to say sound very
narcissistic right now these are my
these this this is my objective in life
let's say da yeah I've got the community
interest let's say for the sake of I'm
going to get married whatever now this
is these are my conditions she doesn't
want she doesn't like them she gets
involved and then after two weeks she
says I'm not going to I want you to
change your conditions I say look I say
I'm afraid to say these are my
conditions now you have a you do have a
choice you can have continue with them
just like a job you know like when you
when you go into a workpl and you s sign
contract if you don't like what you're
getting yourself into then you're fired
effectively then I can go and find
someone who can fulfill that Criterion
the one who has this is what Robert
Green says in his famous Laws of Power
he says the one who's willing to commit
suicide has the
initiative meaning the one who's willing
to walk away from the negotiation is the
the one who's more powerful in the
negotiation yeah so compromis is nothing
to me the compromise doesn't exist in my
vocabulary there only the compromise
that Islam allows in the sense that I
can
compromise no no I mean like I'm not
going to compromise with a woman on like
equal basis do you know what I mean like
there is no there is no there nothing
like that I I I failed to compromise my
compromise is no compromise you know
what I mean no but we're talking about
no no no we're talking about people who
are vulnerable and where their compromis
is coming from so just not the word
compromise it's breaking it down and
looking at it from a different angle
rather than all such and such
compromises on this and so she and he
they compromise so this show is about
educating people not just about talking
about certain things it's about putting
that level of understanding out there
where someone can watch the show
compromise is very important what I
compromise on like let me give give me
an example of something I need to like
not me Muslim like what do I need to
compromise on like do okay like like
like for example I want to hear from
that no no no hold on hold on hold on
when I said compromise I said
specifically on red flags bad things bad
traits bad behaviors no no they're
talking about something else you're
talking about red flag getting like
things that going to cause compromise is
like yeah yeah so in the beginning
people yeah people in the beginning they
see that people have Bad Manners bad
traits they may see something that the
guy may show traits of abuse or psych
okay very simple Shar tongue look look
look for
example a lot wives yeah like if they
have a Shar argument she says saying the
man I know what the man is compromise on
no no no no it's just not man both way
for examp
for ex we know
that I don't want to focus on what the
man needs compromis on first like give
me give me an example red flag so I can
deal with like like I said a sister may
may come to him and she's not in hijab
right she's not wearing hijab and then
the brother's like okay she's not
wearing hijab he's got a problem with it
islamically divor no no before marriage
before marriage gets married and and
then gives her conditional divorce if
you don't wear this no no not inside the
marriage before marriage right
compromise Islamic that's he's guil he's
sinful no he's not like she doesn't wear
hijab no no I'm saying I'm saying like
if if he says to her you have to there's
two things he's not sinful at all if he
says to her you wear hijab and she
doesn't wear it no are you not sinful if
you marry her and she doesn't wear the
hijab and you responsible from the no
I'm not because what do you call it so
she told I told her to do it she's
saying no she's saying no I know I know
that I know but if you compromise are
you not simple when you say I'm going to
put up with you not wearing the hijab
well depends on for example she's
Christian no I'm okay so no doubt there
in that situation there okay what if
she's a new Muslim and she has very
specific situation let's talk about
Muslim born I don't I don't know that's
a very very technical question if he
says to her look I'm going to I'm going
to put like a time table in place for
you to put the hijab on no do you get
what I'm trying to say is that is that I
have to
go compromise no that is a huge
compromise a lot of brothers compromise
on that if you want to say a compromise
from the brother's side lots of men are
married to women who do not wear hijab
right and then later on down the line
it's like put your hijab on okay so the
sister's like hold on you wasn't like
this in the beginning why of a sudden
cases like this what can do if he if
he's if he's tolerating it he can say
look I can I'll give you six months
there's the only two things I can see
happening but talking about reasons for
the marriage breaking down right so I'm
saying that could potentially be a
reason of a man leaving a woman and
saying look you're being disobedient
you're not practicing the way I want you
to but I'm saying in the beginning right
you compromised on that thing so so what
I mean so I don't understand the issue
here so he wants this now she's not
doing it it needs to divorce ultimately
exactly no what I'm saying is I I get
but what I'm saying to you is for me
divorce is not as bad as her not put
hijab on anyway like if I were to get
married to her and then get divorced
it's better that whole situation
islamically speaking is better than her
not put on yeah yeah but what she's
saying is that basically why marriage is
breaking down she saying that's one of
the reasons no CU think about the H of
of talak is Jets m for if I want to
divorce a woman for no reason at all I
wake up sorry very sorry to say this I
marry a woman I spend two weeks with her
and I feel like there's no compatibility
physically everything nothing sorry to
say I cannot live with this person and
sorry to say I'd rather do this sooner
rather than later because it will hurt
you three months down the line now
islamically speaking there's nothing
wrong with this you know say it's led to
divorce there's nothing she had done
nothing wrong mhm what I'm saying is
that divorce is always a bad thing no
it's what we're saying is that what
causes the breakdown so
she what one of the reasons why marriage
may end is because of people
compromising on these specific things
you're right about sister doin the thing
is it all goes back to it all goes back
to obeying Allah you know why because we
hear this a lot as well like in the
circles I'm in here like oh for example
the sister she loves her lipstick mhm
and he's at the beginning like okay you
know what cuz you know he really tra
whatever it may be Etc yeah and then
he's like you know hold on a second bro
you're not going to out lipstick yeah
yeah no you're not going have lipstick
no yeah you're not so the thing is now
then she then this issue comes with the
Western woman side yeah yes he's
controlling me been controlling what the
hell are you talking he got boundaries
what do you mean he doesn't want his
wife with a big red lipstick no no no no
but let's not the opposite the show is
not the we don't want you're right so no
no no it can be sometimes but right now
we're in a pandemic of divorce say the
opposite yeah so so I agree what you're
saying but the point is this that man
has every damn right and if that woman
is going to leave him because of that
salamay bye-bye because if my basic
right of I don't why go with red
lipstick yeah not only that tight
clothes yeah these are things where men
have to become men and the point is that
this is not even a of compromise forget
this so just so the point is I
understand that could be but that is the
reason why marriages are breaking down
because of petty ridiculous
ridiculous issues like this sorry can
can I just add we
to my point is basically in the
beginning like you said you shouldn't
compromise on anything you shouldn't
compromise on boundaries everyone should
have boundaries and everyone should
stick to them and that's how you will
end up with in a successful marriage in
my opinion because if you in the
beginning say listen as as a woman or as
a man as a rajel I am not accepting this
from you and I'm not accepting that like
the brother here said you shouldn't
compromise at all
I feel like the problem is people are
compromising they are for example they
are the marriage how it seemed now how
it is now is different to how it was at
the time of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam marriage now is um it's
seen as the last hope for a lot of
people like it's delayed significantly
to 2530 you have to get a job you have
to do this you have to do that you have
to put your foot on your desires so
marriage itself because of the mount
and the effort that's required to climb
it I don't think we we should really be
entertaining these sorts of things where
we're saying that look where we're using
examples which are anomalies that are
exceptions to the rule and we're saying
that look that can also happen because
we have to look at how marriage as an
institution is it's it's considered now
it seems now and for a lot of people
it's uh it's it's the the end all was it
the the be all and end all yeah the
reason being because a lot of male
suicide is actually linked to the
breakup of relationships and a lot of
female traumatic experiences are linked
to Mar marital issues so I am strictly
against the fact that people think that
they can enter a relationship that a lot
of people you know be it right or wrong
but movies music all of these things do
play a part and relationships are held
to a high esteem and whether we like it
or not that's how we need to regard it
we can't change the way Society is now
so there's a responsibility like there
were a lot of kind of assumptions that
okay and we were going from the
beginning stage where we're selecting a
partner to then compromising I say look
let's just assume from the beginning you
have followed the religion you've spoken
to people of knowledge as you're
supposed to before seeking a partner and
making sure that the boxes are ticked
yeah now that you've done that now
you're going to commit because there's
certain commitments that actually
required nowadays that weren't required
say 13400 years ago which is now if a
man was to marry and let's just say
things don't pan out well he's losing
half of his house he's losing his kids
like life is pretty much over for him
it's going to be very difficult and for
her as well I mean potential for a
second marriage and this and that it's
just not the way it is as it was back in
the day so let's just go back and say
okay when looking for a partner make
sure the boxes are ticked okay now that
you're entering the marriage I'm sorry
you're an adult you're dealing with a
person they have feelings they have a
heart and they have a brain they they
have a purpose in life you cannot just
play about with that person I'm just
going to I'm just going to start I'm
just going to do this and look there's a
responsibility now yeah if you're not
responsible with all due respect like go
live in a cave isn't it like go do your
thing somewhere else but if you're going
to involve another person you need to be
responsible now when you're going to be
responsible you have to understand or we
have to understand that like the sister
was saying there is a topheavy kind of
influx of the way the media tells us
about relationships that I think is a
big weakness that we have because when
we're entering relationships and I'm
going to stick with one theme and one
theme only and that's fighting yeah
fighting how we deal with fighting
because there's Harmony then there's
disharmony then there's repair then the
cycle repeats this is constant and this
will never end somebody who thinks that
there's no disharmony that their
relationship is just not going to
function so sticking on this point
fighting will occur many people are
deluded they think oh everything's going
to be fine a a lot of times in these
movies there's always a big event that
happens that brings the couple together
they never show what happens when things
are at rest
when things are at rest that's when
you're sitting with the that's when
you're speaking to the so what happens
it's how you deal with the fighting it's
the repair that's the most important
thing A lot of people are fighting but
how are they fighting they're throwing
things around again we're bringing a
four horsemen into it yeah the the
criticism how are you criticizing the
person are you you know um swearing at
them are you because contempt is very
serious your name calling your
you're doing all of these sorts of
things I would definitely say to kind of
research those four things contempt
stonewalling you know these things like
you you'd have two couples they both of
them are fighting but then one couple
they will repair because they have
certain principles certain usool certain
maturity levels that place that look
we're not going to go to sleep angry
we're going to make sure we repair by
this time and this is a sign of
emotional maturity how long does it take
you to reach back to line these are the
sorts of questions you need to ask
before you're getting married when's the
last time you got angry when's and how
do you recover from your anger how long
does it take you to recover and reach
back to Baseline because a lot of people
nowadays they do not have the patience
everything is fast fast quick quick
quick quick quick and then suddenly when
it comes to marriage and no no that's
right no it's going to carry on it's
going to spill over yeah so how do you
recover how are you recovering stuff
like this there needs to be you need to
go through you need to read books on
this you need to look at tutorials on
this and you need to make sure you're
asking your Tob partner about this
before you're getting married and then
when you're getting married it's not as
simple as okay you know I'm not happy
with this or this now you're committed
to that person now I'm sorry now you
need to take care of them if there is a
weakness it's not I'm going to ba allow
and I'm going to go I'm sorry this is
not you're going to meet the person at
the Finish Line no you're going to help
them now some people just wait at the
finish line ridiculous some people
they're going through a rough patch or
something someone's passed away you know
something oh no no no he's mentally
traumatizing me what nonsense I don't
feel attracted to what's feeling what
the hell is this I don't I don't feel
like this abstract thing that no one can
quantify and no one knows when it's
going to happen what what ridiculous
thing is this that you are suddenly
relying on this thing and in fact when
you get married to somebody how's how do
you know when the feelings are going to
change how do you know how do you
measure that so we need to be a bit more
pragmatic with this a bit more practical
and that is when these things happen
have things in place in fact the the
founder of the Four Horsemen Dr John
gotsman he actually says amongst other
psychologists as well they said that and
he's got 85% success rate when it comes
to divorce yeah he can tell predictions
predictions and he says that I was
interviewing people and I noticed that
if they had a ratio of 5 to1 that when
they would say stuff about their partner
if there were five positive things one
negative things that's the ratio then
they would survive then it would
continue another another psychologist
therapist said whoever used said
something negative and then use the word
but yeah oh he doesn't you know he
doesn't come on home on time but he
makes me laugh doesn't do this but and
the thing is we're so negative yeah we
we're so negative and another therapist
psychologist says that people I noticed
that the people that journaled what they
did in the day not just what they did
but they feelings as well CU a lot of
times a lot of things are in our head
and they're abstract we don't know what
they are I I feel like this I don't know
what it is what nonsense is this you're
dealing with another person here yeah
you need to find out you need to bloody
find out what those feelings are yeah go
go to a counselor go to a person and you
need to find out you go to a couple's
counselor you go to a therapist
counselor CBD BAC ABC just don't go to
the LGBT yeah so whoever just in invest
in your marriage and do not think that
it's just going to be you to because the
thing is you're the enemy she's the
enemy So you you're trying to solve
stuff when both of you are fire no get a
mediator go to a neutral place and and
and let them hair what's going on get
other people who have knowledge who have
a knowhow that are neutral involved and
work on this thing cuz you're dealing
with people here exactly very profound
may Allah bless you amazing and the
thing is what you touched on as well I'm
go to you guys as well and
sistera no we're going to come to is
he's young how old are you 21 21 M I
think muar is he preparing for the the
marriage aldah we're going to come
to yes yes we're going to come if
there's anything you want to touch upon
as well is is that you know you said for
example red flags Etc as men I'll tell
from a male's perspective yeah with us
and I've noticed a lot I've seen a lot
of people who their first marriages
always fail but their second marriages
work okay I've seen this Trend where
it's and you know where from a man's
perspective where it comes from is the
following men when they marry firstly
it's all about looks yes it's all about
looks and when they marry and realize I
married a shtin yeah this is full out
gin yeah like 50 Gins inside yeah so so
you know I'm being honest absolute sh
and then they're like you know what next
time I Get Married the looks thing let's
let's let's work on that then they come
to reality they're like okay this girl
was 10 out of 10 whatever but she made
my life living hell on Earth
now I'm not going to make the mistake
what do women do women do the same in
the sense where they're like I'm going
to change this man this bad boy yeah I'm
going to you know I'm going to tame him
down I'm going to be the one and then
she realizes he's fully out of control
he's a tapped in the head guy yeah and
then they realize H I learn a lesson and
that's why what you said is very
important because divorce is something
that is you know it's not frowned upon
why because learning from those mistakes
shapes your new marriage and then you
will appreciate your new marriage this
is very very important so
touch up on that because these are the
mistakes you make first marriage is
always from a man's perspective he
chooses for the wrong reasons the sister
choose for the wrong reasons learn
lessons but they don't carry on to the
second marriage you can
quick I was going to say with these
kinds of discussions I always like to
bring it back like as as Muslims right
to our own type of hierarchization right
so the best reason why we can give us
like for example Muslim even now like if
I were to ask why is divorce bad yeah it
would be consequentialist type argument
so you'll say you single parent
households and all the kind of things
right but that's a very specific kind of
marriage that's a marriage where you
have children with a partner right all
right so already we can distinguish
between a marriage where you have
children with a partner and a marriage
where you don't have children with a
partner where you have children with a
partner the consequences of divorce are
actually intensified and everyone can
agree that okay if you have kids with
this person now if you divorce then
you're putting these kids in a bad
position however now like let's say for
example you don't have kids with this
person and you don't like them what does
the religion say about a man leaving a
woman or woman leaving if she feels him
repugnant I mean the woman came to the
prophet Mam and she
said it wasn't for the fear of God that
would have spaten this man's
face the prophet in bukari actually he
divorced them immediately yes but why
because in Islam I'm sorry to say there
isn't this idea that you should be with
someone you do not like I've given two
pie of that one that's they're both
actually women and the other one with
which a very famous had as well so the
only arguments we can really give is
consequentialist type arguments what's
worse than
divorce okay we already said what kind
of divorce is bad from a consequential
perspective is divorce with the family
the worst thing that can come apart from
nap from a divorce is pain okay
heartbreak from either the man or the
woman or both I understand that but like
what's worse pain for two years because
according to the study that was done in
I think it was Bristol University
post-traumatic grief by the way men
spend longer time to recover from from
heartbreak than women apparently the
upper limit is 18 months effectively
like anything other like other than 18
months heartbreak people would not
really report it like 5% or something
like that after 18 months thej majority
people the majority of their pain is
gone according to that study post on
post relationship grief so apart
from Pain heartbreak you got heartbreak
then you've got the kids you don't have
the kids in the situation you've got to
deal with heartbreak if you love the
person if you didn't love the person you
don't even have to deal with that so
okay so in in that in that situation y
here we're we're still faced with
certain situation being married and then
getting divorced situation A you don't
have kids with this person the
consequences of the of the children
being not an equation is there or let's
say for example you're not married but
you're addicted to pornography you're
not lowering your gaze you're not doing
nothing that Islam is saying you're
distracted you're you know you you're
actually still in pain from your PR
whatever it may be right which of the
two situations better for me even if I'm
not going to say like these Scholars who
say marriage with the intention of
divorce they actually mention with the
intention of divorce right I'm not going
to say go into any marriage I agree with
you I mean with anyone right do not go
into any marriage with the intention of
divorce but what if you go into a
marriage and say the following with the
following intention I'm going to go into
this marriage I'm going to test the wars
I don't know if I'm going to be with
this woman for the rest of my life or
not how about that how because that
intention for me is is better than being
going into like effectively pornography
addiction or Z which are the two big Els
of the time let me let me tell you
something like do you know when we say
that times have changed it's true but
let's follow let's consider the
following as as an individual yeah look
at the attitude this is a sah look at
the attitude towards divorce that people
had towards her she was sahab she had
married four of the sahabis men she had
married what do you call Talib yeah she
had married AB bak sik and one other
person who I forget who is and even to
the point where she was asked the
question like who who from your husbands
did you like the most and then she said
from the older men it was Abu Bakr and
from the younger men it was Ali and then
what you call it Ali sorry it was jaff
and Ali said what about me you've left
nothing for me so it was all lazy fair
and comical and like you would not
imagine in today's age that kind of
attitude towards divorce being the case
like okay this woman has married this
guy and his friend here or his cousin do
you get what I'm saying it's out of
imagine this one woman has married this
guy and his friend over there like it's
to be honest with you it's it's a bit
off key like in today's age you would
accept it what I'm saying is what you're
saying is just just to wrap up the point
is is that if there's any age in human
history where we need to have more of a
Las Fair attitude towards nah in my
opinion is today's age why because if if
you don't
have that laser attitude then the
repercussions are quite bad okay I think
it's very important to understand that
it's not a taboo thing we don't want to
make it seem like divorce it's something
that you cannot you cannot do and it's
simple ET or not but okay but can we
before we go to the because I think this
is I've been waiting for a while
now in it yeah sister you can speak
first I want to touch up on um you
mentioned pornography so marriage is not
cure for a man or a woman who are
addicted to pornography or a toxic
person or a Mommy's boy you know you
know where sometimes the mothers will
say oh he'll be okay once he gets
married so marriage is not cure for
these type of people the other thing is
um I work with sisters and couples and
at the moment from the past now people
are starting to get educated on uh not
trying to change people but that was one
of the common denominators that I'm
going to change this person or I'm going
to change her once they get married
that's a big problem and many many many
divorces have happened because of that
reason
and the other one is where the parents
think marriage is a cure for their sons
that are you know Offroad and you know
going the other way so you know I don't
want to mention each thing but you know
we can all agree on that that marriage
is not okay for these type of people you
know about pornography in Z that's a
prophetic
advice was
ask whoever can of you let him get
married let him get married other words
what the prophet's advice to towards
marriage was pretty lazy pH like whoever
can do it just do it let's talk about
the people that can't get married that
should not get
married no okay okay you mention fasting
but then there are okay there are
individuals guys guys topic is G
somewhere else I'm so sorry forgive
we're talking about we're talking about
why marriage is bre so I'm I'm trying to
stay on that why marriage is why is
marriage is breaking very for changing
people thinking marriage is a cure for
toxic people marriage is a cure for
mommy's boys you know if you're going to
get Mommy's boy married off he he'll
always be a mommy but he'll see that
woman as his mother and if she doesn't
um you know behave like that or deliver
in that way then he's going to think
that marriage is failed I think I think
one of the biggest not just I'm going to
come to and sister as well the thing is
the biggest what i' I've realized from
Little that I speak to around people
because I'm dealing with that situation
like I'm looking at what's going on is
this um third people getting involved
other people getting involved it's the
Crux one of the CR of the matter what it
is is that people go to advice you need
to understand I see marriage like
this this clothing that I'm wearing and
my wife wears it's tailored to us it's
not it's I when I go and buy I have a
site a waste site you get trying to say
same with my wife it's like a clothing
that we're wearing it's like somebody
else coming to my marriage and saying
hey why don't you try my clothes on and
I'm like oh it might not feel it might
too too big for me no no no I think will
be good the reason I'm giv this example
is because what happens is when marri
disputes happen the husband or the wife
goes to somebody else and now they're
giving advice based on their marriage
and their standards and they're like
brother yours is bespoke for you and
mine has been spoke for me yes General
see you can give but what happens is
then these advises are given you should
do this or you should do that my
husband's not like that your Dynamics
with your husband is totally different
to mine the N you given me is doesn't
fit me it's the cloth you giv me it's
I'm wearing and it's extra extra extra
large or it's extra extra extra small
and I'm like I'm a bit uncomfortable no
no it work it work it doesn't so one of
the reason I found out is found is that
people going and seeking advice from
people who might be look mature people
but the don't give me advice based on
how your marriage works so Zan you
pressed the buzzer yeah five minutes ago
yeah and you're not I just wanted to let
you know it means nothing we're
go was less it's the first time you
pressed
alhamdulillah it's it's it's really sad
that we have you here but we have to we
have no choice if you add some uh two
pen spe if you have anything yeah so I'm
going to say what I need to say Al yes I
leave yeah you have everyone has one and
half minute you have 30 seconds yeah I'm
joking minute go now I've got 1 hour so
look the the thing is um today there's a
there's a great lack of boundaries
there's an attack and the thing is the
Family Life the family unit has become
extremely significant because of the
rise of the LGBT and we need to Bear
these things into consideration the
family unit has become really
significant and that's why rather than
we keep missing the the first point
which is finding your partner we have to
assume that the partner has been found
we've done we've ticked the boxes
because I'm sure the viewers they know
that there's certain considerations
certain things that you need to look at
first now after that's done there's a
saying that somebody said and I think
it's very profound and maybe people that
are a bit older tend to understand this
because when you're younger you tend to
think the gross is greener on the other
side you have a lot of options and maybe
you're getting pinged there and their
messages fair enough they say a soulmate
is somebody who you decide to make it
work with there's no one that's meant to
be it's someone that you decide that
you're going to make it work with that
person and the thing is somehow people
that are over 30 they're like 33 35 they
found their soulmate why is that the
case because they've decided to make it
work they've decided we''ve done enough
now we're going to make it work so it
comes back to this exact thing make sure
you've ticked your boxes at the
beginning and then make sure you have
the tools in Your Arsenal and your tool
chest that will help to deal with those
arguments because it's those arguments
that people can't deal with they can't
handle and it's them that get spiraled
at that time you'll insult the
Mother-in-law you'll say something or
you you maybe insult someone's religion
or something like that and a person
remember that for the rest of their life
so um certain things get said because
those people just don't know or you
don't know how to handle that person and
people give up too quickly I think true
I want to go to you as a young man
you're not married like we've all been
married here when you hear this is it
scary for you is it like you know what
like this is some goodness here I can
benefit from no no he's a young a young
he's young he's got to be learning so
like what would you say like how do you
feel when it comes to divorce when you
hear it you know so what I'll say is
like um definitely it's a lot harder I
would say in this generation the new
generation of like I'd say after 2000 is
going to be very difficult because a lot
of people are nowadays like they're very
immature and they've been raised in a
very immature way and like um I just
personally I think the best thing to do
is just like not try and reinvent the
wheel just go look at your parents look
at your grandparents that's probably the
best thing to do and like a lot of
people nowadays they think they can
change things and like make things
different with yeah and he worked with
them he worked with the older generation
I just yeah I think that's probably the
best approach try and go for what works
and don't try and like um change it and
like copying ideologies like you know we
think we think we know it all can I yeah
people act like they know
more things that's right anything when I
let's go she hasn't spoken and then
sister op and then S I think brother Zan
sort of covered everything I was going
to say but the only thing I'd like to
add is that um a lot of us need to get
our head out of the sky and come back to
earth because we have really high
expectations and almost romanticizes
what marriage is we look at Tik Tok for
marriage couple goals and and none of
that is real I think the sooner we
realize that it's all fake the better
it'll be for our own selves I think we
need to start looking like other brother
said closer to home so rather than
looking for Role Models online look at
home look at how your dad treats your
mom and if he doesn't treat her right
learn from that understand that that's
not how I'm going to treat my wife or my
husband you know not everybody has great
examples at home but you can still put
two two together and make it work
regardless and I think we have a low
tolerance devil and we have high
expectations and how is that supposed to
even work and I think that's another
issue we don't have patience we we lack
commun um we lack communication skills
we lack listening skills we communicate
to argue and to be right rather than Sol
listen to reply rather than listen to
learn exactly so I think there's quite a
lot of few things I think people that
are looking to get married should always
always always look within themselves and
ask themselves like if I was to be faced
with this problem tomorrow say my
husband wants to go and get a second
wife how would I deal with it like ask
yourself you know what what strategies
do I have that I can Implement and that
I can actually put on the table we don't
look within ourselves we just think
right I'm going to go with the flow I'm
going to just go with the wind and when
it's time to get married I'm going to
find somebody and get married but we
don't do the inner work and I think
that's where the issues happen because
if you've got drama that's you that
you've unhealed from that's going to
bleed out eventually and then you almost
expect marriage to fix that and it's
like oh the other person your better
half as they call it to fix that and
your better half isn't going to fix that
you need to fix that you don't take
baggage with you you know whatever it is
um so yeah I think doing a lot of inner
work is going to help have a successful
marriage having patience definitely um
we get worked up and ticked off so
quickly these days and it's like people
have become overly sensitive you can't
even make a joke without them crying
about it and I think we need to toughen
up a little bit we've become very weak
over the years and you know what's
interesting like for example if you look
at the Quran and the Sunnah yeah like
there was time where the Prophet he's he
his wife gave him a hard time this the
best man to walk this earth and the best
of woman yeah but he didn't divorce them
one of them he did yes yes one of them
but if you look at generally and what
they were doing and stuff yeah there was
so many situations but he was in a peak
situation where you know at one point he
left them all and they fear like did he
divorce them but the point is this they
went through those struggles ups and
downs but divorce and again when it's
not that it's found upon but the divorce
didn't was not really mentioned but
today anything small that happens
divorce this divorce and you're looking
at it and the prophet dealt with so many
imagine going through all of that and
then coming home and sometimes the wives
are causing issues and but he never ever
like not I would say never ever but
majority of the time he didn't resort to
and he was dealing with it so since door
me and
yeah um I was going to mention about um
add to the brother sorry I don't
remember his
name um he mentioned about people giving
up to qu and stuff like that and when it
comes to the problems in the marriage
people having arguments and fighting a
client of mine and she doesn't mind me
mentioning this it was the end of the
marriage right according to what
happened and the scenario and she asked
her dad what should I do in this case
and her dad said to her it all depends
on how much you can tolerate So based on
what her dad said to her depends on how
much you can tolerate she then went away
and said to the husband should we get
counseling that was refused right so
based on his refusal he ended and
resulted in divorce so a lot of people
are not exercising the things that are
actually available to them which is
counseling it's shunned upon and I think
it actually can save a lot of more
marriages if people actually looked into
is is from you guys experience is does
counseling like marriage counseling does
it help save
marriages in the Quran we do have this
you
know if you fear I mean this is one
thing that if you pay attention to the
tenses here and the yeah persons in that
in that a if you fear that they're going
to divorce each other bring a judge from
their family and her family and a judge
from his family right so it's as if it's
the community initiative the community
should take the initiative to save the
the family the the marriage the
community is destroying it now they
coming together destroy it yeah so so I
was going to say like in terms of this
marriage counsel and stuff like to what
do we have evidence to show that it's
effective well a lot of people don't op
for that's the problem we don't even
know we don't have enough results
because a lot of people try kind of
thing 100% 100% because I feel like if
you've got that to the end of the
marriage where you're both just
disagreeing on everything and it's got
physical some people are fighting
physically people are fighting over the
kids kids are seeing this and one of the
spouses say let's get counseling let's
get therapy we can't communicate we
can't cooperate let's get help from the
outside whether it's im or profession
from the prophets there was famous
Hadith where this it's not counseling
but it's kind of like arbitration you
yeah well no it's and the prophet had an
argument okay and then afterwards like
they said let's bring a let's bring a
third third party to sort it out M so
they started rattling off names and and
like you know the prophet she was like
no no he's going to take your side too
much Etc so they came to the conclusion
that it's going to be like abak sik yeah
you notice what MTH I know you I'll let
you
finish I I'll let you finish okay fine
anyway what happened was yeah so AB came
to the house yeah and then when he came
in as soon as a started complaining
about the prophet he went mad he started
like lashing out and stuff like that and
so obviously the prophet told him to
leave cuz he brought he he brought over
this he brought him him over to solve
the situation not to make it worse so he
was making it worse but but when he left
he the prophet said look you see how
I've got him out of there you know I've
got him out of there you know and then
sik came back and he said that so you
call me over in times of Peace but you
don't call me um you call me over in
times of War but you don't call me over
in times of Peace the point being is you
just use the negative out no no no I'm
not saying that's negative I'm I'm
saying that proves your point in a sense
that it's good to bring a third part
yeah a third party um into the mix and
stuff was the end result of that Hadi
what happened what happened was
that he wasn't he wasn't effectual it
was better for them like in that
situation for them to solve it by
themselves and then he brought them back
back in I'm just saying it can work
that's an ideal scenario actually sorry
that's an ideal scenario cuz some people
actually go to marriage counseling right
and then just one session they start to
communicate better and then they're like
you know Ash we can reason with each
other you know what sister do you know
what should I tell you something you
it's like antibiotics you have to take
the full CA some people go for one
session I think we've learned everything
now it's true but but you know what
Muslim Council are definitely help sorry
sorry sorry I have to add when when we
talk about counseling as well it's got
to come from both sides it it it's got
to be agreeable like you have a lot of
just women going to the counselor okay
cuz women are women and we always crying
and moaning okay always asking for we
try no no we try to it's actually the
study that showed that 60 to 75% and we
are the compromisers we are the
compromisers right it's true you guys
the compromis with the compromisers yeah
as we should be we were created to
compromise so it's always the woman
going and and I'm no no offense to the
guys but most of the time the men yeah
do not want to go to this because I
don't know why that counseling
obligation that's actually very true you
know to call up the brothers my question
to the brothers is why do you not want
to go if you want to save your marriage
why would you know if he doesn't want to
go like well it's to save your marriage
okay can I can I answer your question
question yes
please about does counseling really work
now if you have an understanding of
counseling if you have an understanding
of uh counseling you won't be saying
that because the thing is when you go to
a counselor the first thing as a Muslim
counselor the first thing I ask is do
you pray Salah what is your relationship
yes are you on the
May more of you your
relationship you know with Allah
that is priority that is priority
because okay between two people who is
the third shanan is there to break your
married he will whisper to the you know
Wasa to the wife and wasasa to the
husband true you know she's not worth it
you can do better especially now with
Facebook and social media it's easy you
just go click up and that's it yeah okay
okay yeah but then you know same go goes
with the sisters they're flicking
through Facebook and Instagram
everything you know oh this brother is
practicing my husband's not this brother
prays five times a day you know all
these kind of things so that is the
first thing that you know is uh fixed so
start praying your Salah you know make
that solid and then we go on to
self-reflection now why why do marriages
fail because we're attacking each other
we're not reflecting on ourselves so
counsel a counselor or a therapist will
teach you the Frameworks
for example another for example another
thing about a counselor is by by
definition a counselor is not supposed
to necessarily tell you what to do and
they're not supposed to judge they're
supposed to guide you they're supposed
to help you reach your own conclusion
and I've seen this a lot with counselors
unfortunately they're not following this
Golden Rule and the thing is and a lot
of brothers have complained saying you
know we go to this counselor they're
siding with the misses or you know like
this or like that so the Golden Rule
before so that's the thing sometimes one
session is done and then that session is
skewed they're not following the Golden
Rule they're not following ethics and
because of that people Cel people may
can cancel that but also a man feels
that he's in charge of his relationship
and they and he feels that it's a sign
of weakness to give control to to
somebody else so again this is something
that I think it's it's a it's a niche
it's it's something that's missing
within our community that we have good I
mean unfortunately and sadly that's why
you've got people like Jordan Peterson
that have taken advantage of this and if
we think of a comparison in the Muslim
Community I don't think there's anybody
that's as charismatic that that speaks
well he's up and coming you know yeah
watch this SP watch this
face come on okay can I can I just touch
on can I just touch on what brother
brother said there um brothers are going
to counsel us um judging by what brother
Z zishan just said
um they're not counselors they can't be
counselors if they're putting their own
biased thoughts and belief system into
guiding someone else you can't do that
as a counselor psychologist or you can't
do that okay all
right I'm not saying say anything one
second no okay guys we need to wrap this
up because it went for quite a bit I
think it was very very interesting
alhamdulillah may Allah bless you guys
and like we said before guys the
solution is in the Quran and the Sunnah
and of course the psychiatrist and the
marriage counselors Etc then go to that
but please start within start with that
inshallah and hope you guys benefited
from this episode work on yourselves as
well work on yourselves as
well work on yourselves as well till
next time from the bitter truth with
amazing guests our honorable sisters may
Allah bless them
in the prophet wasallam said whoever
builds a Masjid for the sake of Allah
subhana tala Allah will build for him a
similar house in jenah on that day where
Allah subhana T tells us that our books
will be given and every little atam
weight of Good Deed You' th will be
there and imagine you see a mountain and
you're like what a lucky person which
righteous person and Allah says this is
for you for me yes what did I do you
allowed people to pray you built a
Masjid I never had the money to build a
Masid Allah you helped you gave towards
it and Allah gives you the reward of as
if you built it donate now guys and do
not delay and share the video for extra
[Music]
Rewards
oh